here's what would happen if you jumped
on every planet in the solar system
at home on Earth if you're an average
jumper you should be able to squat swing
your arms and leap about half meter high
in about one second on Mercury you could
jump three times as high as on Earth and
your jumps on Venus would be slightly
higher too bars would leave you feeling
lighter in your jumps you'd get about
the same height here as you would on
Mercury since Mars has 10 times less
mass than Earth Jupiter's intense
gravity would leave you feeling much
heavier than you do right now if you
tried to jump you'd only be able to get
a pathetic 20 centimeters off the ground
and watch your balance Jupiter and
Saturn don't have surfaces you need to
jump from on top of your spaceship
beware of slipping on the dark cold
windy surfaces of Uranus and Neptune you
wouldn't want to take a fall on these
ice giants so